does anyone else with a sibling with a
disability have this conversation a lot
sheena how can i find someone to go on a
date with
wait i should start from the beginning
this is me and my little brother sean
ever since he came along he was my best
bud and i just wanted to take care of
him
before he turned one we found out that
he had cerebral palsy
but to me he was always just sean so we
were like any other pair of siblings
and for a while there really got at each
other but i swear
now we get along much better so my
brother has cerebral palsy and a lot of
things in life are a little more
challenging for him
one of those things is dating but i
decided
i'm gonna sit down and talk to him about
dating and then i'm gonna find him
a date so first i asked him
why is it important for him to date i
feel lonely
i want to be with someone i tried my
best and asking
my friends like if they
want to go on coffee dates
it's hard to know who to ask out and
when you just have things in common and
when you're just friends and when it's a
genuine connection that could turn into
something more
romantic but i feel like it's easier for
people who have no disability at
all like you for example me i tried
asking
my crush in middle school it was a
junior senior dance
she stood me up i think it's hard for me
to find someone because my disability
people just look at me weird
[Music]
walking my talking people
i feel say i don't like i don't want to
go out with that
i just watch people more flexible
so what kind of stuff would you want to
do if you got a girlfriend
i would want to
do hand gliding
i'm talking about just like everyday
stuff okay
stuff like going on the treadmill
walking out you guys both gonna be on
one treadmill at the same time yeah um
singing
playing video games playing board games
watching movies going out
other than the treadmill part all those
sound like really fun data yes
how about we find you a date yay since
we are
in the time of covid we are going to be
looking for a virtual date right
and i will be using the power of the
internet to find this lady
so i'm going to take a few notes on what
we are looking for
and um what you want to share about
yourself so how would you describe
yourself i'm funny creative
okay and outgoing
yes very true what is something else
that you want people to know about you
my short business of course should we
show people yeah
let's see your shirt all right
so this is inkman yeah and you have a
few different designs huh that you've
drawn
and where do these come from these
characters
i just thought of them my imagination
and where can we find your art in your
t-shirts on my instagram page
i think i have enough information now to
scour the web and see if i can find a
lovely lady for you to go on a virtual
date with
awesome awesome shawn has been wanting a
girlfriend
for ages like he has been talking about
wanting to go on dates and meet someone
for
so long he just wants to experience
romance and love and not unrequited love
we all just want to be loved and to love
right and
i sure hope he finds that one day and in
the meantime i'm gonna do what i can to
help
okay sean i have found a few lovely
ladies who are interested in going on a
virtual date with you
and we're gonna look through them and
you're gonna choose one okay
okay option number one she's looking for
a long-term relationship with someone
who she can be comfortable around
who is her best friend and they can have
fun together
and number two she plays the keyboard
plays video games likes to go on hikes
this is our final option she's looking
for a man who is kind and is able to get
her out of her shell a bit
she loves movies and going to concerts
wanna see more about her
yeah hi i'm melissa um i live
outside of pittsburgh pa and my hobbies
are
i like reading and watching tv
and are puzzles
yeah is she a winner yeah yeah yes
all right we will be setting you up on a
date with
melissa yay
hey bud you excited for your date today
yeah
then let's get ready hi hi
nice to meet you um how
how are you oh i'm good how are you
good okay i'm sitting in the other room
and
i'm so nervous for him she seems very
high functioning
and maybe even neurotypical with just
some physical disabilities
and that's something that's really
interesting about cp is that cp is a
very
kind of umbrella term where there are a
lot of variations in what cp can look
like
so some people just have a little bit of
a waddle in their walk
and some muscle weakness but they are
totally neurotypical
some people are very severely disabled
and need 24 7 care
and can't really do much on their own
so sean falls kind of in the middle of
everything
and that's why he can be so tricky i
think when it comes to dating and
finding a partner
because a lot of the people he knows
kind of
fall on either one end or the other he
just needs to find someone that will
love him for who he is and
it's not about the disability right it's
just about finding someone who
intellectually
can match him in a fun way we'll see how
this goes
how did it go um it went really well
but i want to keep as friends
because she lives too far away and i
don't want to
i don't want to move there yeah that
makes sense well i'm glad you had fun
though and it sounds like you made a new
friend
yay i'm so excited to see
who else is out there and
i want to keep on dating so ladies
if he's your type i am still down to
matchmake so hit us up
also if anyone else knows other ways to
meet people
for people like sean let us know
[Music]
you